ich glaube nicht dass ich das es also
sorry aber ich weiß jetzt einfach mal
rein
[Musik]
das ist mir noch nach oben da wenn ihr
noch so eine folge sehen wollt schreibt
im restaurant in die kommentare bei navy
was geht ab und er zu bekommen bei einem
video leute es ist wirklich ein sehr
spontanes video eigentlich könnte sie ja
auch für mich macht sehr viele spontane
videos ich finde das ist einfach das
geilste so das macht am meisten spaß
und ja sehr gut begründet der mitte
schon spät ich kann das jetzt das haus
und meine vision zu drehenden wind unter
der woche an einem donnerstag licht
ausmachen
stromsparen scheiße in dem ich gerne 14
die frage ist was machen wir jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon gelesen vor
ungefähr einer woche kam das video von
mir das schlechteste es ist schon ein
bisschen länger her das schlechteste
restaurant in köln also das schlechteste
restaurant laut google rezension mit 2,3
stern so und ich hab da schon weiter
gesucht und habe einen burger laden
gefunden ja er wurde mit vor irgendwie
gar nicht angezeigt haben konkret nach
berger und ihr werdet es nicht glauben
er hat einfach 1,3 sterne sind traurig
einen burger läuft das ding ist nämlich
ich liebe bürger ich kenne mich extrem
gut mit bürgern aus ich habe bestimmt in
meinem leben schon bei über 100
verschiedenen burger restaurants
gegessen obwohl gerade frisch
gewaschenen und sowas danke und da
musste ich wirklich direkt sagen ey com
das musst du selber ausprobieren
übrigens mein auto sieht ja echt böse
aus schaut euch das mal an die felgen
sind wieder schwarz megageil also im
kontrast und gelben politik das bestimmt
cool aus
[Musik]
na ja der bürger hat ist sieben
kilometer entfernt von hier ja wie
gesagt 1,3 stände extrem krass ich würde
sagen bevor wir jetzt losfahren seht ihr
hier im video erstmal die ganzen
rezensionen dazu und das zeige ich euch
jetzt so leute herzlich willkommen zu
alex sterne analyse stunden oder ich hab
natürlich eben schon mal alleine für
mich so ein bisschen gelesen ja lieber
analytics und soweit ganz gut
so also das ganze wird erstmal
weitestgehend zensiert wir haben hier
1,3 sterne also die stelle passen
keineswegs zu diesem bild hier der
bürger sieht man nicht echt lecker sie
haben elf cool rezensionen und die
schauen wir uns jetzt mal zusammen an
der martin schreibt mal wieder eine
maßlose enttäuschung das essen kommt
einfach nicht aber mein geld scheint man
zu benötigen
hoffentlich schreitet hier einmal eine
entsprechende stelle ein und prüft
dieses unternehmen telefonisch
erreichbar ist niemand einstellen ist
zuviel verbrecher zwei stunden fahrzeit
nur die halbe bestellung kam an und das
was an karma falsch werde dafür sorgen
dass dieser laden geschlossen wird und
wenn es das letzte ist was ich tue
haare auf dem essen frisch war es
vielleicht letztes jahr ich habe davon
eher bruch 21 euro für drei bürger -
obwohl drei deutsche das blöde ist ich
nehme das ganze jetzt im nachhinein auf
ich habe eben schon mal probiert habe
mich gefreut auch das essen bezahlt
wurde via paypal aber das essen waren
hier danke für nicht ich sage vorweg das
beste war dass bürger brötchen ohne
dieses hätte ich einen stellen gegeben
pastorin stellen gegeben es wurde nicht
die dosen geliefert welche bei der
bestellung angegeben waren
der hat aber raus ja auch nicht also
dass sie war sehr schlecht dann kamen
update wir haben im laden eine zweite
chance geben leider burger brötchen war
gummi und der burger hatte wieder
avocadocreme dafür irgendeinen chilisoße
nochmal der salat frisch käse auf keinem
lager zu finden wie beim letzten mal
also wir schauen uns hier mal kurz
nicht appetitlich aus ich weiß nicht wer
also da bin ich raus gefällt gerade hier
auf dieses schild auch aktuell hängt
dann nämlich ein anderes das schild was
selbst hängt das schild aber auch
irgendwas mit pizza drauf und nicht mit
bürger also anscheinend reicht das geld
dann nicht mal für den neues schild was
ich jetzt noch ganz kurz sagen was aber
er ist auch überhaupt nicht zufrieden
geben sich aber auch alle mühe das ist
ja so dass die meisten hier einfach
bestellt haben übers internet ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob man das positiv oder
negativ sehen sollte auf der einen seite
seid froh dass ihr den laden von ähnlich
gesehen habt und euch so der appetit
aufs essen vergangen ist auf der anderen
seite also hygienisch ist das essen auf
keinen fall naja soviel darf so jetzt
schon selbst was ich von hat und wie es
bei mir verlaufen ist viel spaß also
leute aufgeht ich bin wirklich gespannt
was ist es dafür personal
ich wundere mich auch dass die noch
offen haben ankunft 23 uhr 23 also wenn
man auf jeden fall schon halb zwölf die
haben bis 2 uhr geöffnet
ja mal sehen ob ich da rein komme und
ich habe auch wirklich ein bisschen ich
bin mitten in einem wohngebiet und ich
habe diesen laden ich dachte daher kommt
auf jeden fall keinen laden mehr habe
dann fahre ich so weiter und plötzlich
erster sein
keine ahnung das war aber kein berger
laden ist ja sowas wie so ein liefer
haus als wir da hallt es könnte man eine
pizza holen oder so und das war halt
genau die richtige adresse aber da ist
nicht der berge laden für die firma
ultra komisch mal hin und mal gucken so
ihr seht mich wahrscheinlich gerade
nicht so gut dass auf mein handy
gewechselt nicht da jetzt kurz zu fuß
hin und mal gucken ob die wirklich was
zu essen für mich ein sehr sehr
komischer laden das ja irgendwie so ein
bisschen kriminell auswendig also wie
man sieht hier sind wirklich nur so
heiser und da leuchtet
gelbes schild leute da ist ich muss
wirklich sagen ich habe absolut nicht
klar
ich habe noch nie so etwas gesehen
das war katastrophal wenn ich mir gerade
vorstelle
manche restaurants deren essen fertig
machen
da hat es nach pisse gestunken wirklich
nach pisse und ich hatte keinen plan wo
das herkommt der mülleimer war über
gequollen alter die soße hatten das war
das billigste vom billigsten die wand
von ja und die waren leer und stadt
alltag wirklich schockiert glaube nicht
dass ich das es also sorry aber so lange
zurück im auto was ich noch sagen wollte
also ich esse eigentlich wirklich vieles
und ich bin echt nicht pingelig ja bei
so was es geht nicht ich werde
vielleicht einmal rein weiß ich habe
keine ahnung aber ihr könnt euch nicht
vorstellen was ich mir ich bin gerade
wirklich übertrieben schockiert die
haben leute die da das essen bestellen
und das komplett also dass hier einmal
diesen billig käse von jahr drauf
geklatscht und dafür dann neun euro ich
will gar nicht wissen was ist von
fleisches bevor wir jetzt aber weiter
meckern gefahren erst mal nach hause
aber das ist so schlimm wird hätte ich
niemals gedacht wirklich also leute das
ist das essen ketchup hier drin in den
google rezension stand er das ist extrem
fertig ist ich glaube wer ist jetzt
extrem fertig wird man hier schon so
dass fred merken weil ich bin da zehn
minuten auto gefahren
das glaube ich eben schon mal ein blind
und aber wir gerne nochmal der lage so
lieferanten total abgebrannt der
kinderecke ich tatsächlich jungs ist
dass ärzte könnten nicht so wirklich ein
land führen
[Musik]
ich habe wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung
sich so ein laden hält man muss
natürlich sagen die bieter da war
wahrscheinlich nicht hoch geschätzten
250 euro maximal im monat löse bei
solchen lädt es ist wirklich so dass
dinge der bis 2 uhr auf und welcher
bürgerladen geliefert ich glaube ich ja
auch welche bürger haben hat so lange
aufbleiben hamburg auf burger hier in
köln haben bestellt war wirklich einmal
da wurde ich wäre jetzt auch gar nichts
verurteilt ich habe es ja noch nicht
probiert ich habe zwar ein schlechtes
gewissen das zu essen muss natürlich
sein wenn wirklich etwas nervös wir
machen das mal auf was kriegen wir jetzt
hier zu sehen
das ist der bürger hätte ich da jetzt
bestellen würde ich vermutlich sagen
sieht ja gar nicht so schlecht aus aber
ich habe die ganze zeit diesen
hintergedanken im kopf wie das gemacht
wurde diese salatblätter die lagen auf
der theke total 1 gekommen als würden
die da schon eine woche so liegen also
ich würd sagen wir fangen erst mal mit
dem komme es an
so also bei der muss sagen ich finde nur
einmal strecken wir gut sind zwar
relativ klick aber nicht schlecht leute
kommen wir als nächstes zu dem burger ja
ich denke mal vorsichtig heraus ich weiß
jetzt einfach mal rein
denn
[Musik]
einmal noch also eine wirklich ehrliche
meinung der laden von innen katastrophe
täglich wäre das ja nicht anders könnte
ich das jetzt super guten gewissens
essen ich muss sagen wenn man das ganze
jetzt versuchen aus würden die pommes
wirklich gut der bürger eigentlich auch
okay der käse schmeckt zwar sehr billig
trotzdem ist es jetzt keinen bürger wo
ich sage das ist aber gar nicht möglich
macht all die vom geschmack her ist der
eine stern auf jeden fall nicht
berechtigt muss man so sagen will es
hatte ja glaub ich auch damit zu tun
dass die lieferzeiten einfach so ewig
lange waren was ist nun schon kalt war
wenn das jetzt kalt ist gut ist es
vielleicht nicht mehr wirklich so
genießbar also ich finde rein vom essen
er hätte es schon drei sterne verdient
vom gesamtpaket her ist der eine stern
vielleicht sogar berechtigt weil wir
gesagt das innere von diesem restaurant
katastrophe die leute also abschließend
kann man auch sagen ich habe da für neun
euro bezahlt wird auf neun euro
aufgerundet weil der bürger hat 95
kostet die pommes glaube ich 250 werden
im video das restaurant komplett
zensieren ich will hier niemanden was
böses oder so christian lässt sich in
diesem fall sagen die rezension stimmen
ja ich bin wirklich um eine erfahrung
reicher dass wir noch nach oben da wenn
ihr noch so die folge sehen wollt
schreibt im restaurant in die kommentare
rheinberger hat irgendwas matisse an der
form ist und das war kein catcher
schreiben das heißt auch in die
kommentare
wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen tag
kein